you are listening to the hot breath
podcast i am your host comedian joel
byers
and welcome to your weekly guide to
comedy
mastery with desi just doing that
piece of professionalism you know that's
uh
that makes a big difference in this game
i like these knights yeah yeah
yeah podcast this is a blues
blue encore two hundreds yeah it's dope
you like that it matches the match of
the year
like i'm just you gleam you blinking
yeah i thought everybody say i'm about
to take this i thought say let me hold
something
yeah and i got you some water too
this is fontes this is our our water
sponsor i like it bro
this is uh georgia spring water from the
blue ridge mountains
i can taste them you taste the mountain
in that that's good stuff
we collaborated on some labels they do
custom labels and stuff so
we out here see we're doing big things
oh yeah man it looks like
it looked like we were in a hospital
before i went and stole this tree from
that start to sign in you know
well dude thanks for doing this almost
definitely seriously i feel like with
this setup it's like we're in between
two ferns or between two joel's right
now i feel like i need to introduce the
show
he's like hey all welcome to hot breath
podcast we're here with my guest desi
banks desi banks welcome to the hot
breath verse how you doing my brother
hey welcome welcome thanks for having me
oh you know i'm asking you thanks for
having me
dude you are you are red hot right now
my friend slow down
trying to stay you know become hot you
know oh yeah yeah
you're not you're not you don't think
you're even bubbling yet
i'm bubbling okay you know but i haven't
you know got to where i want to be yet
you know you know as far as
building to where i'm trying to go yeah
and hold the mic um yeah
because we're in a hospital
and see we ain't made it yet we're out
here just doing interviews where we can
there you go i'm in here just stealing
plants like desi will understand
because you will understand so you're
clearly like how old are you
25 25 yeah so dude yeah i'm
sorry i'm trying to steal popping the
cherries you're so young dude yeah yeah
which i'm sure you hear you're so young
you're kids or whatever
but i feel like i'm 35. oh why so
i don't know i guess because i've been
so into it you know ever since i started
yeah you know like 2012 right yeah on
vine yeah
and the first video you do goes viral
crazy what yeah
dude how was that predestination i don't
know and you know
when it happened i was just like
wait a minute like this is really
happening and my friend was like
you might as well just keep going now
yeah and i'm saying so i just stayed
consistent i just kept going and you
know started building that
you know that fan base you know so just
been going ever since man
so i all started with the atl talk atl
talk bro
let them know what was it what the hell
i was talking about you know what i'm
saying somebody
getting into a fight you know and i was
telling about a dude you know i'm saying
he running
into a fight but him being scared he's
not one of you know what i'm saying
fight anybody and it was like this
atlanta talk atlanta slaying type of
thing you know and and then in the south
atlanta slang
so what's going on you know my ponder
head no you don't say hey
you know something like that but it was
a lot of talk video and it went viral
man
and you know it was a good thing it had
to be a good sign
yeah and it was like you know god was
like this is it man this this is where
you're gonna find your purpose at
yeah you know once i found that purpose
man it was it was everything man
and that was were you just like in your
living room like this was not a big
production i was in a room yeah i don't
know it was you're like in front of
shades yeah whatever like it was i was
in my room like literally in my room
and it just sparked my mind i said i'm
gonna do this boom and i did it and
posted it and maybe like 10 minutes
later my phone was just
i was like wait a minute yeah what is
this yeah it was crazy
it was crazy like some app my friend
tells me about and now i'm like blowing
up on it instantly
yeah and as i was being consistent on
vine you know my fan base was building
up man and i was just like okay
wow um i may be up to something you know
but
like at that time though i wasn't taken
as serious
only because i was in college and i was
playing sports yeah football right
wide receiver yeah i played receiver
edge um i was at georgia state my fact
at the time
moorhead though you started morehead
and then i transferred um to georgia
state and finished up mm-hmm so once i
got to georgia state
that's when i like really got back on to
it
you know what i'm saying in 2015 once i
graduated
okay i really start back doing it
because you know in between once i was
doing football i wasn't
as focused on the social media you know
what i'm saying like i wanted to be you
know
because of sports so you think you're
going to the league did you get i didn't
thought i was going to the league i
thought i was going to the nfl that's
why i was like you know i ain't worried
about no social media i'm going to nvl
so you know i'm going to tell you this
here i just knew that atlanta falcons
was going to sign me
and then no but the atlanta panthers
you got the the the people yeah yeah the
georgia state panthers yeah it's a good
consolation
yeah well i was wondering what was the
second vine so you probably post the
first one you're like oh i'm
i'm a prodigy and then did the second
one bomb i don't know if it
i can't even remember oh okay you you
delete the
the losses i do yeah yeah yeah yeah i do
delete the losses um
i don't remember what my second video
was
um i'm pretty sure i kept it up there
just because you know what i'm saying
at that time because in the beginning
stages it's like you're just trying to
put stuff out there you're just really
trying to find yourself
yeah so you don't know what the people
like just yet you just really got to be
consistent
at doing something then you go like okay
you might did
been done like 10 videos and then you
could like really say okay they like
these
what the what gets response yeah so now
i got to start doing more of this
gotcha that's when i like you know found
that niche with that so
yeah it seems what's impressive about
your portfolio and it is a portfolio
like
between ig and facebook and youtube
someone might blow up on one and they
may have a million followers on
instagram and then facebook they may
have like 5 000 likes
yeah all platforms most definitely
you're dominating it most definitely
that is that's very rare
like how we've been able to achieve like
such notoriety across
every platform see i would say i would
say because of the
the content that i do put out you know
the stuff that i put out
i like to relate i like to yeah
get in the mic there yeah i like the
relationship this is show biz
i'm preparing myself but um i like to
relate to the people
okay from young kids to the older
people you know what i'm saying um i do
a lot of character work
which involved like family you know so i
like to involve like you know family you
know relationship
problems family problems and you know
stuff that people went through you know
growing up
so like my age range is from like i
would say maybe like 14
you know but it's probably still some
younger people watch it but you know on
facebook it's the older crowd
yeah you know so i know what they like
and i know what they want to see and
it's like instagram although i know this
what they want to see
and it's like youtube they like
everything
you know i'm saying in twitter it's like
they can like everything
you know but facebook is like really
just for the old people it's not too
many young people that's on
like facebook i mean you have a few but
young people is more of
instagram okay and it's like i kind of
like found the balance
you know with that i would say i mean
i'm still kind of
probably not a 100 but i'm at a
good percentage of you know with it
so you're maybe creating content you'll
only release on facebook and stuff
you'll only release on instagram you
won't like cross-pollinate well now
i'm at a point where i make it fall
okay yeah you know what i'm saying
because everybody likes
the relationship problems everybody have
a baby mama that they deal with
you know from the young to the older
everybody
has the the bad child the bad kid
everybody have a grandmother
everybody have a uncle or a granddaddy
you know that they do these things that
goes on in my video
so now it's like it's like you know it's
leveled out
you know i'm saying to a point where i
can put it on
every platform but did that take time to
build into
yeah okay it took some time because you
know i would say like literally
like for real for real i really
just maybe found my niche and like you
know people really started to like
get involved more i would say probably
what is it 2018 now i would say
the beginning of 2017 was really when
things really started to
pick up pickup you know when i started
to see like that change big numbers
uh-huh what was that pivot you think um
once you know of course i got with some
great actresses you know i'm saying
shout out to b simone and
candice and you know nunu and just all
the people that i work with and
we all got that chemistry you know we
all connected well
you know what i'm saying we we built
that and we stayed consistent
you know and the people started to love
it you know i'm saying
my vision with what i do you know what
i'm saying of course i want a sitcom one
day so
yeah i try to put work in with that so
that people can like
visualize it as like a sitcom and you
know i get comments like oh my god i
can't wait to see this on tv
and that's like very inspiring to me
it's like okay i'm doing something
good that the people love so they can
like really see it on tv
you know so that's how i'm like wow i
got something yeah you know
just on the amount of time you know i'm
saying it
your team just stand close and everybody
believing that it can happen
not only me but them as well and sharing
the same vision yeah
cause it's like you know i mean i can't
do it by myself you know so and
it's not just about you know for me it's
for them too because this can be
something big for them as well
you know so that's that's how i look at
it and the people
they love it you know i i ate it
probably they'll probably freak out if i
came in with another girlfriend
or another baby mama they were like wait
a minute this is not no
you know yeah because they they like
what they say that's like for example if
martin
brought in another girlfriend it's not
gina man people like what is this
we want gina you know so that's it's at
a point i feel like it's
it doesn't get they don't sunk into that
and people love it
and people love it on social media and
i'm sure you've been in the rooms with
very influential people now and powerful
people and
people almost the invisible hand of
entertainment and where the tide is
headed
do you even think tv is the way to go
oh man um social media is being so
strong
man and i want to say tv
but so many people is on his phone yeah
all the time talking about with netflix
with youtube
you even got the the stuff like hbo and
stars they got apps for that now yeah so
it's like they can still just watch it
on their phones so it's like
i don't know it's like because i want to
make it to the tv okay and when i make
it to the tv
you need to be turned on the tv don't be
on your phone
so but i don't know man social media is
becoming a
real big impact to the world it's
becoming
too big man yeah i'm not saying it's a
bad thing but
i mean if that's where it goes i mean
it's fine
i mean i'm not going to complain but
because that's i mean you're already
established there
yeah so it's like going to tv it's
almost like okay
now you got to herd them to this as
opposed to it sounds like they're
already invested like youtube is almost
is a tv channel yeah especially with the
amount of eyeballs you're getting is
more than
yeah a lot of tv shows yeah yeah is
there something just to that
you you just love martin and you think
the desi bank show is like a martin
so you just want to see it on tv just
for you yeah man it's like a dream like
a you know it's like a big thing
to like yeah me growing up watching
martin and being inspired by his shows
and you know
eddie murphy being my favorite actor you
know i'm saying
i want to be able to do some of the
things that they did as well but in my
way not saying i want to be like them
but in a dizzy way you know what i'm
saying so yeah
and this yeah man to get these numbers
you're getting a thing you've
harped on a couple of times is
consistency yeah that's the that's going
to more detail on that consistency i'm
someone like
putting out videos i mean you can't like
you know in the beginning stage you just
can't
put like one video out a week and just
think that's it
you know what i'm saying you got to put
like in the beginning like when it was
15 second videos
like literally i probably posted like
four videos a day
a day a day okay you know
until i got to a point okay now
i can slow down now they seen me a few
times so now i can drop down to two
videos a day
and you know here come one minute video
so now it's like okay now i got one
minute videos
now i can do one video a day or
two to three videos a week you know i i
don't have to put too much pressure on
myself
drop it down to that much yeah four a
day to two a week you know what i'm
saying
oh okay you know once you done built
that
you know once you don't got to a point
where you can like okay cool
now you you have the time to focus on
other you
focus on this but also focus on other
things as well as far as like you know
building on the outside of your brand
you know what i'm saying doing
things are going to be able to take you
to another level outside of social media
kind of things like um i would say like
acting
you know i'm saying um going to acting
classes
and stand up you know being on stages
and preparing myself for things like
that
uh because that is gonna be able to
give you a whole another type of you
know i look at social media now as
it's like your foundation is your brand
and it's like now
okay what else you gonna do you just
just gonna do social media or are you
gonna
like where are you gonna take your
talents to you know and so with this
platform
when they see me on tv now these these
are people they're gonna go watch me on
tv
you know and it's gonna make you look
like okay now it's gonna be inspiring to
the people like dang he started from
here
now he there yeah you know what i'm
saying so that's how i like
look at things that's why i wanna touch
that tv platform
you know business sitcoms tv shows and
being in movies and stuff like that you
know stand up
you know and stuff like that so yeah man
that's
the leverages in those followers like
yeah it is you see wild and out
everybody's phenomenal they all have
followers that's the resume
yeah so it's phenomenal bro it's you
know
once you get to that level man and it's
like once you get to the tv level it's
like now okay
you there but now it's on you now now
you got to keep your foot in that door
now you know what i'm saying you got to
stay consistent at working hard so i
feel i look like a social media right
now
i feel like it's a stepping stone it's
preparing you for some things because
once you get to that level
your work that they gotta be on times
ten boom
yes and you gotta be that much more
consistent oh man
yeah and a lot of that a lot of
consistency can come from organization
most definitely so how does organization
play into how you move
um i would say focus and you know having
the correct team
you know around you to keep you at a
level
of you know time trying to get to that
point you know um
of course i have a agent acting agent
gotcha that give me
these opportunities as far as going in
these audition audition rooms and
you know meeting these directors being
on set with um you know major
producers and directors and you know
stuff like that that's going to be able
to elevate me to that level
um but i would say man getting to the
level you got to have a team you can't
do it by yourself boom
you can't do it by yourself man and it
can be really tough
really really tough by doing about it
you know i've spent the social media
part
you probably have to do that by yourself
to build it up
to build it up you know and then once
you get to a point then that's when
somebody will come say okay he don't
build something let me grab him up
you know let me help them out you know
because some you got to help yourself
first
before somebody else help you man you
know a lot of people think
people are just going to come and just
come on man but you got to put your work
in it man they got to be able to trust
to know what they got like the person
that they they know they only
gonna work hard you know so they know
they're gonna stay consistent they know
they're gonna do these things
so you know invest in but you know
maybe you get a mindset like you know
hey
i don't build this now i can do the
business and i can bring my team in and
you know i don't have to like really
worry about you know that's why i said
shout out to like issa rae
you know yeah she you know i look at
people like that like you know she
didn't wait on nobody you know
because social media gives you a point
like you don't have to wait on nobody
you don't you can do everything yourself
you know what i'm saying so
it's you know it's a lot that goes in
this stuff man and as a comedian
specifically
that's where like all comedians are like
oh man how do i go viral
how do i blow up what am i doing wrong
like what are some
what are some common mistakes you're
seeing comics make in the social media
world
uh it's the consistency man that's the x
factor
because you know like you say like for
you know was once as you keep going
you're gonna find
you're gonna find an itch but the thing
is to keep going though
see a lot of people well first you got
to love it
yes if you love it you're going to keep
going you're going to i love this like i
don't care what the results i get i
don't care i'm going to keep going no
matter where i love doing this
and as you keep going you're going to
find out
you're going to find out what the world
been missing like you're going to find
that thing the world love
you know because it took me some time to
really like find my niche like
i used to be the point like hey like
what can i do consistently and i don't
have to do other stuff that's like weird
and awkward
you know what i'm saying consistency
that the people is gonna love
and people you know they worry they're
so worried about going viral
but to be honest it's really they need
to worry about finding that niche
you know find that niche find out
what you like to do and not what the
people like
that's what they gravitate towards the
authenticity yeah
yeah cause a lot of your videos that you
thought were gonna go viral
it don't it's the opposite right it's
the op i'm to my bra
it it's so crazy and now i'll be at a
poem like i just when i post the i mean
of course i wanted to do good
but it's not me it's up to the people
it's what the people like but i it's
like i don't
done a few things to know
what they like so that's kind of an
advantage that i do kind of have
but you got to keep going to like really
find that niche though
you know so when did you feel like was
it was it a repost
or like what what took you from okay i'm
being consistent i'm hammering it out
until you're like
oh i found it when i thought when i like
when i said when i start doing stuff
with
other people like beast of my own and
candace and that's when it took off i
started to see
like the team yeah you know i'm saying
that's how i say i couldn't i can't
to that level it's like you can't do it
by yourself
you know i mean i'm naturally funny you
know
but once you found that team and it's
like you find
yourself you find a lot of stuff that's
you know it's
it's like you find the thing that god
got for you you know what i'm saying so
no mo dick there you go
yeah that took off yeah that's you know
and it's so crazy
when i said that it just came to my mind
it's just improv yeah that whole thing
was improv
oh wow yeah i think we said the idea
like we want to do
and she came in already you know you
know i was just something she clicked in
my house like
no more day and it's so crazy it's so
crazy because in my mind
it's like don't say that say that and it
kept going
no more no more is this god's plan
and i'm like okay cool and before i
pause you know
it's gonna be funny i don't know if it's
gonna be funny or not you know what i'm
saying
dog posted it yo it was crazy i had like
but we had probably had like two to
three hundred comments in like
six minutes and i was like oh yeah
yeah yeah 50 cent jumped on two yeah
yeah he um he reposted it he reposted
another um video that we did as well
but yeah you know and
it's a it was crazy bro i was just like
and that's been like a thing like every
time somebody see me now they might be
like no more dick
there's no more big guy and you're like
it's
stuff like that that people don't
it's like you don't write those things
down you can't write that down
right those moments like you know even
like with martin
i i feel like you know some of his stuff
was empire like for example like you
know with jerome jerome
had i say he didn't write i'm pretty
sure he didn't write that it was just
character yeah it's just character you
know what i'm saying yeah there's stuff
like that that sticks
i don't think you can write those things
you can't write that stuff man this is
meant to be
it is just guys you know it's just
natural bro so
what is the most time you've spent on an
instagram video because i've i've played
around with a little bit
where it's like oh it's a 60 second
sketch we'll knock that out and it's
like three hours later
you're like wait what yeah like it's a
production what's the most time you
spent on
these videos like two hours bro oh yeah
yeah like two i'm talking about like
really trying to get the correct take
and
you know this person gotta answer the
phone i got to go through some and it's
just
oh i got to edit it down i don't like to
take that out and
you know yeah this is but that's like
what cutting
see now i kind of like made it a little
easier for myself
see now what i do now is
to not even work so hard i just
we shoot everything i you know i write
it down
and we shoot everything no cuts no
nothing we just we go back and forth
right here so
the only thing that i'd be cutting is
the end in the beginning
and the video is done i don't have to
worry about
cutting we gonna get this tape right
here and that's gonna be it
and i was like you know so cause in the
beginning i was like okay this is a lot
of cutting i'm getting tired of cutting
stuff
exactly i need to make it simple it
can't be consistent with that you know
you're cutting oh man you'll get tired
of that so yes i got the point where i
just
shoot it out and you know you know found
that way
so yeah and you found the sustainable
because that's the big thing with
consistency
is if it's stressful it's not
sustainable it's not you know yeah
and there it is it'll show yeah yeah it
is
and you know they'll see it so yeah
that's what i've learned i went through
a phase now i'm just i'm all in on hot
breath like i'm just i'm just building
this yeah as like a platform yeah and
that's that's my new
kind of that's my new motivation that's
where i'm gonna be drawing
fans in most definitely i went through a
phase on like joel byers comedy where
i'm like
i'm gonna be political i'm gonna shoot
sketches and i'm gonna have comments
every day about
what's happening in the news man i did
about three of like just looking at the
camera things and the cutting and i'm
like nah
that ain't it that ain't it
no more vids so
i found it through listening to people
that most of my feedback is coming from
the podcast and all they learn from it
and the cool guests i get on here so i'm
like
oh like you said listening to your
followers what do they want okay
give them flood them with that i'm
telling you yeah
make them fall in love with it you know
inspire him with it man
and connect with him like what i like
seeing the most is when i see comments
like
when people say oh i went through that
man i know exactly that feeling
you know oh i miss my grandmother man i
wish my grandmother was still living
it's like you know i'm touching them
through
real life situations and that's like
what my comedy is about i like to stay
relatable
because to be honest i feel like
everybody that went through
somewhat of the same stuff as like
growing up and like dealing with like a
relationship problem baby mama
problems and you know it is all light to
what i do you know
even though i have a baby mama like in
my videos you know
is it's nothing negative
you know about the situations it's like
it's a lot of people out here you know
that don't deal with a baby mamas
you know i'm saying it at a certain
extent but it's like i even see
comments like let me call my baby mama
man you know what i'm saying to like you
know
you never know what that can lead up to
and they might
be watching a video together even though
they
didn't like each other at the moment
that video might connect them and be
like look at this why we can't be like
this
you know what i'm saying yeah yeah it's
like you know i'm saying and you never
know that can bring people
together you know so keep it focused on
the family
yeah you know what i'm saying it's
really all my videos really just it's
just
love man and and you know and just
bringing that peace it's never it's it's
not really ever no
negative in none of my videos
i don't pour out the negativity so
that's almost something you put your
content
through is like a filter is like is is
this positive is this about love
it has to it has to have that most
definitely got to connect
okay it has to it has to connect in a
positive
light that the people love you know
it has to and it seems what you've
referred to as
it has to connect with you first most
definitely so it's that's so interesting
about social media it's almost like the
more personal the more universal
most definitely interesting most
definitely and most definitely
yeah that's that's the a big key
yeah so if you create something and
you're not that into it
but you create something to be viral but
you don't care the audience isn't gonna
care no they're not the exact opposite
though create what you want to see most
definitely you got it you got to create
you got to feel it
in your good that okay i like this
like when i do my videos and we do takes
it's like okay that's the one
you know i feel like that's the one so
i'm gonna put this out
you know and we're gonna get the
universe to respond to it you know
so once you feel that connect okay
that's good then
you put that out you know i don't i
don't try to outdo my other video
because sometimes you know i can find
one and then
i try to do another taking this like i
try to outdo that one but really that
was the one
exactly you know and you know in the
back of your mind yeah i'll m.j
[Music]
yeah yeah and thinking of this
connection we're always like
yeah i'll just do what my followers want
but it seems like on social media
there's also
algorithms at play here oh yeah so what
is what's what's that world about it's
like you
with my algorithm of course you got to
know when to post
um and my times are like prime time i
post around
it depends on the day it's so crazy
because on sundays i post around about
4 35 midday and do you schedule your
posts like do you put them into like a
scheduler and
put them up ahead of time you know it'll
be no no no like a content calendar yeah
have you heard of people doing that i
have for you
no no okay um but during the week i post
around 7 15 p.m
during the week saturdays i post at 11
30 in the morning
11 15 11 30 in the morning not in the
evening because saturdays everybody is
out
you know um
and yeah you know the algorithm is
really based on like
your consistency of posting you know it
it
it very it goes up and down you know
with the amount of views that you get
and the likes and the
the you know the comments and you know
the engage that you get with your fans
you know that it just plays a balance
but big thing is knowing when the post
and
is that through like analytics yeah and
it show you okay you know they tell you
the best time to post but it's like i
found without their analytics i found
the best time for me that's that's good
and like that's been consistent for me
which is 7 15
you know for the people you know so how
did you find that number for yourself
are you tracking are you keeping notes
of like okay
i posted at six this week i posted it at
6 00 p.m on sunday
did okay oh this week i posted it at
seven did even better
it's definitely you're trying it's just
like
and it was at a point where i was
posting at like 8 39 which was cool
uh but it would be like some people will
probably be off some people ought to be
asleep
you know so i'm like nah that's probably
not not good so i dropped down to 7 15.
it's like it's like that that right
interesting they're right you know
that right time of the day you know some
people just get off work
you know some people may be laying in
the bed some people
i don't you know is that that right
they're right i feel like you said
right that sweet spot you know for me
you know and then it's it's really
it's just some water too yeah it's
really some of that it's really um
knowing your fans age range as well okay
you know so my biggest range i would say
is from like
uh
21 to like
25. is this instagram yeah talking okay
but you know i still have like 30 you
know but like the biggest is probably
like 21 to 25 that's like my
biggest range and knowing
that there are young people you know
what i'm saying so it's like
that that that flat level that 715 is
like the the thing
and it's a different i think that's
another good note is knowing who your
audience is so
your audience may be 715 my audience
maybe exactly
comedians that are out at a show at 9 00
p.m exactly just knowing when that is
and maybe a weekend evening
maybe a good time to post a video as
maybe a tuesday morning is better to
post like an image
or something like that too most
definitely see with images
i probably said it was good as you said
it with images i post around about
i would say 11 in the morning 12. you
know
those good for images you know just
something they could just scroll
you know and just you know especially in
the morning
you know in the morning it just depends
on what the video is i mean people ain't
trying to
and then maybe it worked yeah yeah yeah
yeah
you know if it's a picture it's just
like oh but you know but
it might be a word that can't listen to
it i can't laugh i didn't say i'll watch
this later and when i get off or
something
you know you know it's something like
that so yeah
what about facebook like it seems like
we're just about instagram what about
facebook is the same i
i when i post some on instagram i post
it i post
i go i actually post it on twitter first
huh yeah
and it you know it's like crazy i found
the thing too
see twitter is like my test
you know i post it on twitter first and
if i see twitter it's doing good on
twitter
okay i know exactly what it's gonna do
on instagram i know exactly what it's
gonna do on facebook
i know exactly what it's gonna do on
youtube so if you don't do good on
it if you don't give me my good feeling
on twitter i don't post it
so it's like it's like a cheat sheet
uh-huh you know what i'm saying
like that's what kind of like keep me
safe you know i posted on twitter first
okay if it's let's say for example like
50 retweets in 67 minutes that's
phenomenal on my twitter page
you know so if i see that it's like okay
oh it's going to be a good video on
instagram i'm not even going to worry
about it facebook i know it's going to
do good you know what i'm saying
now if it's like 15
retweets in six minutes ah i'm not
posting that
i'm not posting that one you know but
it's like a cc i mean you know that's
nice
yeah it's like a beta tester yeah
testing if it's worth going
most definitely into the skyway most
definitely can this get off the runway
before we throw it off the cliff
there you go so yeah twitter is like
that that cheat sheet for me
to like you know before i post anything
so how important are captions in all
that game oh it's bee
yeah because they're they're looking at
that caption before they even watch the
video
interesting yeah so if it gotta be it
gotta pop to the people
it has to pop to the people so how do
you make it pop to the people um
just depending on what you're saying
like what i would say for okay baby mom
video
um when your baby mama
steer your money or it's still key word
when your baby mama
whoop your son or when your baby it just
you know it can't just be when your baby
mama
when you're tripping it's gonna be like
an action yeah yeah
yeah tripping yeah yeah yeah
like take the d yeah
you know they're like oh wait wait wait
look at that wait what is it yeah that's
true you know like you know
right yeah what is he doing
it's those key words that make him go
watch uh-huh
you know gotcha so once that caption
pop-up okay boom i can watch it now
yeah it but it's got to be concise i see
some people do like paragraphs do you
know you depend on the follow-up depends
on your follow-up
it just depends um
yeah it depends on the following i mean
i've been
straight straight up with my you know
straight up simple
boom post you know so but with uh with
the content um
not limit content length instagram 60
seconds what length of video do you find
works for like a facebook
because that's got to matter too it's
like facebook it's a longer video so
they may be more likely to consume three
minutes while on youtube they may
consume
20. but is facebook like a smaller
window of time have you found no
facebook is
it can be a minute or more well like
what uh what the
what the followers like what will they
usually there's got to be a sweet spot
with even the link to the content right
i've just been a minute just two minutes
on facebook yeah whatever i post on
twitter youtube instagram
it's all a minute i know they want more
but it's like you'll get more
on some either doing longer stuff or
like you know being on tv
or right now it's like just taking i
want to see more man like
i want to see you in a movie man like
you know they want to see you they want
to see you do more
yeah but it's like i can do these right
now until
okay i feel like they they want to see
more but i feel like
when there's more time
it's like you got to do more if that
makes sense
like in promoting it or no i'm just like
like with a minute okay once they laugh
at that minute
haha all right what do you got that next
minute got to be funny too
and then next bending got to be funny
too yeah okay yeah you know what i'm
saying
you're thinking in sketches you know
what i'm saying it's longer it's gotta
be yeah i just feel like a minute
i mean it's good for the people right
now especially with attention spans
like it has to be funny funny funny keep
going you know i'm not saying i can't do
but
when when i'm doing that level i want to
be like doing like sitcom stuff and
doing like sk you know more sketch stuff
and
episodic stuff and you know stuff like
that i guess i was just thinking for hot
breath and how i'll post like interview
clips
yeah and on instagram i'll post minute
snippets of stuff but on facebook i may
do a three to five minutes seven
minute clip but that's a little easier
to
just snip that as opposed to writing a
seven-minute sketch
it's a completely different so i guess i
was thinking in those terms
of just how i can apply your knowledge
to helping build hot breath
do you have any insight for me brother
banks do you have any insight for me
we'll see on the interview side that can
be different but it's still good that
you put your
um your minute clips you know as far as
like being on um
instagram um you do like you know have a
link in your bio
yeah to the full yeah because i post the
full interview on youtube
and i'll clip it up for instagram and
then i've been doing clips
for like linkedin and um facebook longer
ones
but maybe a minute is all they really
care about still and i don't think
i don't know if instagram would get
extra time only because of facebook
and they like connected with each other
it's like yeah once you get
instagram this mother much of the time
on facebook that might kind of like pull
some people from facebook and
break them over to instagram because
instagram is like really
it's just a big thing it's really big
out of all of them that's the one that
you
yeah i think it's very interesting but
you know it's crazy it's on facebook
they have some interesting stories i
like to like watch and look at it
it's a lot of stuff that's on there but
it's more
with that stuff it's more like real life
things that's happening
you know yeah with the whole facebook
thing
it's like like a news yeah that's what i
was gonna say like facebook is more like
a news channel instagram is more like
your entertainment
you know okay that's an interesting way
to even look at cutting up interviews to
where maybe
more entertaining clips are on instagram
and the more informative ones
are on facebook yeah
that's what i was looking for that kind
of sparked me that kind of helped me out
yeah that's interesting
yeah i didn't even think about it like
that yeah yeah
because i was i saw on your like youtube
the desi bank show
that's like how long is that video 20 20
minutes the episode did it the short
film the short film yeah it's like 23
minutes
so did you oh for sitcom length right
yeah yeah yeah this guy right here
this guy you know at the commercials is
some 30 minutes thinking about it all
because that's that's
sitcom yeah yeah and i did that i did
that
i did that what like two years ago and
you could tell
nutty professor was your favorite movie
that's the jam right i know
it bro yes bro
yes bro yes this is doing
all the characters yeah man and i it's
like when i was doing i'm like that's
what eddie murphy went through man i'm
like i feel
you know it i might not been on the
eddie murphy level but i'm like
i can do it yeah you're doing no one you
know you're doing it man you know so
once a big old budget come in and you
got some big people who want to like and
that is
you know because even that looked legit
like oh yeah
it was good very well done it was good
yeah i had fun shooting it you know so
how important is production quality in a
social media post
oh it's big it got to be clear you can't
shoot with no android
it's not going to work take that
androids it's not going to we're
watching this on android just shut it
off because your whole life is shut down
please
please don't i'm sorry you know android
is not a
now it's just not built i iphones are
built
for chats yeah it is built for shooting
and editing
it is it is androids are built for
suckers i guess
even though i have an android i got an i
got a galaxy s6
actually i'm waiting on these sponsors
to come through man i need
i need an apple sponsor
[Laughter]
eventually right yeah it's one step at a
time most definitely yes yeah
patience because if you can and that's
something important for
like um a comedian that maybe is posting
sketches
and it is on an android as opposed to an
actual like camera which now people are
shooting cameras
shooting skits on like red cams and
stuff like dslrs like it's that
professional now yeah
that's that's oh that's phenomenal but
it's important i think for somebody
starting out
or just on the hustle and all they have
is an android still
oh still do it yeah don't don't let that
stop you the rest yeah don't let that
stop you
yeah cause you never know they i know
it's a camera but you probably be funny
you know what i'm saying exactly don't
worry about that you know i'm just
saying we're just talking about the
quality
exactly you know so use what you got
yeah don't let this believe if you can
do
more with less you get more most you can
do everything most definitely oh i like
that quote
i like that yeah you can do more with
less
when you get more you can do everything
most definitely more do anything
yeah yeah that's the that's the t said
that
yes i don't steal it that's what he said
yeah that's what i loved and watching i
watched the desi bank show and i was
because i knew you were a fan of eddie
murphy and martin and like mike epps and
all this and then seeing this production
i'm like
yo like i i knew who you were before
before doing this interview but i always
like in-depth research my guests and
when i started looking into you
i was like oh whoa this
isn't just somebody who's funny on
instagram this is someone who has
actually built a platform
really like a media company is what
you've done
in a very short amount of time yeah is
that what you're seeing in the long term
tyler perry studios type oh man i would
love that
that you see that that's very inspiring
i can see that i can
i can see it you know i can see it
i can see it you know but like i said
with
stuff like that i'm pretty sure like you
know tyler p
he had like a team of people that did
their job man
and you got to have that you know
and god let's not forget about god you
know and
no more dick nobody yeah i'm sorry i
just love hearing interviews like i
gotta give it up to god yeah just keep
thinking no more
yeah but yeah yeah
everybody got to be doing a job there's
only so much a person can do
yeah by himself because there's so many
talented people that's out there
but it's like they need that
extra help man like you need that x you
got it you need that like
i don't care like you need that man you
need that team you need them people
you need that with people doing their
part you know everybody doing that part
what are some tips for comedians like
new and old because everybody
you're almost doing the reverse you you
blew up on social media
and now you're getting into the stand-up
game as a lot of us
you know i've been doing comedy a little
over eight and a half years now i've
been working at gilig stand up and now
i'm like okay how can i build a
following how can i let people know
about this what are some tips you have
for comics in that space um i would
you know from my end point uh
social media is totally different from
the stage it's a whole different ball
game it's just
it's nothing to play with i would say um
but if you like if you funny if you feel
like you're funny
you know you can find a niche on the
stage and not just be doing it because
somebody else said oh you got this
amount of following bro you got to do
this
you got to want to do it it got to be
something that you really want to do
man because there's only one take on
that stage
you can't cut net now you know
it's you can't cut it you can't say okay
let's do it again
no they gonna look at you like what
preach preach you're supposed to be a
professional right right right you know
but
you got to know the gifts and talents
that god has blessed you with
wants to go into that stage now you know
yeah you know what's the worst you've
bombed how long you been doing stand up
six months have you been booed yet i had
people walked out what's the worst bomb
oh man i had people walked out bro i was
just like
yo and i it's like i felt it but i was
like i'm not going to stop i'm going to
keep going
through i'm going to wrangle them in
yeah and i was like oh my god and that's
like us
like i think because of my approach of
what i
said and that like kind of messed up
everything from the beginning and i was
like oh they didn't like that
do you remember what you said i think i
was talking about where i was
in a not so good way and they wasn't
feeling it
they wasn't filling it up oh like the
actual room yeah you're making fun of
the room
yeah that's a good way to turn people
off yeah cause they're like even if it's
12 people and you're making fun of the
12 people it's like
hey we're here so yeah we're not here to
ruin your night we're here to support
you and
make that mistake and then it was like
okay and it was like oh whatever
bye they started walking out
i learned from it though you know yes
you learn from i mean it's good to go
through those type of situations because
it's like really okay
it's like god testing you do you want to
do this because this is part of this you
know
and it's like okay okay okay i haven't
been through it
you know i know how that feels i know
how to quiet feel and i know
when people not laughing and not
interested i know them feeling so it's
like
that's fine just go find what works you
know just continue to learn from that
because
i feel like a lot of the great stuff
been through situations like that where
everybody yes so i feel like if you
don't have a story to tell with that i
mean
if it's just that easy for you i mean
like dang like that's the benchmark
question on this
podcast i ask every comic on here like
what's your boo story yeah or what's
your worst bomb
everybody has because i feel like i was
very like
i couldn't believe it you're like
depressed after yeah i was like very
depressed bro and i'm just like
oh man this is crazy and i had to keep
reminding myself man you funny i don't
care you funny forget what the people
say bro you funny bro like it don't
matter
it don't matter you funny you funny
don't let this you know forget them
people
it's like i can't tweet this one out
yeah
you know no retweets no laughs yeah you
know and people was giving me advice
after the show like look it's all right
man just
you know it's cool man you know it's
good it's good
and like i say once you feel it that one
time it's like okay
okay okay so if it happened again it's
like oh okay
i don't have some good shows that i have
some occasions you know i know you know
you learned to deal with it yeah failure
is the best teacher yeah man
it's you know once you don't felt it at
one time it's like okay i'm good man
and if it come again i know how to deal
with it it'll come again
yeah i'm not putting voodoo on you no no
no no i understand yeah man
so it's like yeah and that wasn't the
only time that wasn't the one it's been
plenty of times i don't want a room it's
like quiet and i haven't got what you
know i
said joe you know him with a point like
bye
okay that didn't work
yeah and then like okay
yeah i don't have though but in but when
somebody had told me before because i
used to be like
hey this joke didn't work here but it
went good here
yeah you know it's like don't take it
away it's just some stuff just you just
gotta figure out what work and that's
like you know knowing the crowds
yes that's a big thing like before you
go up see who's in the room like watch
you know see what's um
who's in here yeah what else are they
laughing at the comments before you what
are they getting laughs
what style do they like yeah yeah and
it's it's so much see
it's so much stand up that you have to
learn
there's an algorithm oh man you got to
learn that stuff
and that's the process of everything
like i'm going through that process
right now figuring i'm still figuring
that figuring everything out right now
so
just like you said with social media
it's got to be something you want to do
because or the work won't be worth it
you got to want to stand up yeah
you see people with that hour special
you didn't see the 20 hours of failure
behind that space exactly
that's straight up oh man because oh my
god
jesus christ goodness
that i was special it looked good but i
know they went through
so much just to get to that point
yeah you're doing all the right things
man so like you
you're building it up it seems like
you're you're giving the proper
attention to everything along the way
most definitely building it
incrementally and that's going to be
that strong foundation yeah
eventually everything will be here on
the same level yeah
you know i believe it dude yeah and i
i've been a fan of you
and your work i could tell just from the
amount of content you're putting out the
work ethic is there and you're clearly
talented
but then to look at it's literally it's
a portfolio
of your body of work and have been able
to translate into doing films in africa
yeah at 25. and then you get uh
recognized in africa it was crucial
which you're just like won't it
i couldn't believe it dude yo i couldn't
believe that that was like
that was like the light of that whole
like trip like knowing people
know you in africa what they say to you
like i was eating and the girl came up
to me she was like oh my god you
you the boy from instagram i'm like wait
a minute i'm 16 and a half hours
over the water not even you know driving
on the other side like
what yeah this is crazy
you know that was like really inspiring
it's like
that's how like you know i know i'm
doing what i'm supposed to be doing like
when you connect with people
across the world that's that's that's
it's like
if you give up you giving up on so many
people it's like dang like
he don't do like you me you make people
days you inspire people
help others chase their dreams you know
help people find out what they love to
do and that's the beauty of it like
that's the purpose of
you know why i do what i do so yeah man
to actually inspire you
yeah it's not just about entertaining we
also
inspiring people man motivating people
because you know
i do you know even though like you said
they don't see the they just see the
video they don't know what we go through
on the other side you know this the
pressure that you own and
how you got to keep pushing through this
stuff to keep feeding the people
you know because it's not about you it's
really now it's about the people now
it's crucial yeah listen to what they
want and give them more yeah man
so yeah i feel like
in the and you're getting recognized in
africa and
shooting a film over there it's it just
seems like
there are no boundaries anymore in terms
of
entertainment and that's where tv
they're kind of tv almost creates like a
box
and you get stuck within that box but
the internet
has it's it's infinite it is it's
infinite it is
it's beyond it's like it's you don't
have to wait
yes you don't have to wait anymore you
don't have to
like you can create your own short films
you can create your own movie because
it's okay i can't remember who i was
watching but
he was in an interview i can't think of
an actor name you know they was
talking about you know people say they
wanna do you wanna be an actor
or you you you just wanna act you know
and it you know like what do you wanna
do okay you say you wanna be an actor
okay
but create your own stuff then you'll be
active you know what i'm saying is
you want the fame and you want to be on
that level because
it's like what do you want like what is
it that you want
you know what i'm saying because if we
can create a short family
we're acting but it's really the fame
it's really that big thing that people
are
chasing i think having clarity in your
goals is crucial
so you know where you're headed most
definitely some people are like oh i
want to
i want to go on instagram get a million
followers okay why
yeah what do you want to do with it most
definitely you gotta have a plan you
gotta have a plan
yeah and once you find that that's
another thing once you find that plan
it's like everything will continue to
grow as well
yeah will you actually write down your
plans most definitely
you have to write the goals down i write
goals down
like it's like now like the platform
that i have on
the mindset i have the platform i have
on instagram is for
everything on the outside it's for
movies it's for tv it's for
the next level stuff it's for people to
come to my shows
you know it's now instagram is just a
platform for me
you know it's all my supporters i want i
want my supporters to to be
inspired of me going to the next level i
want them to see that man i
i i gotta i want to get to another level
just to show them how how god worked
you know and he can do it if you believe
but you got to believe he can do it
you know and having goals i've heard
people almost
they'll visualize them or they'll write
them down every day or
they will actually take time to write
down their goals
and then just let them almost let them
almost ferment
and come to life and you can physically
see them before they actually happen
most definitely because i don't written
out a a few goals that
that has once i focused on them it came
to pass
and it's it's like you really have to be
focused on what you you written i think
success is
focus is a big part of being successful
as well and knowing what
what it is that you really want to do
and once
you focus in on that
and you find purpose in that and you be
consistent into that
eventually you're gonna get what you
what you written down
eventually it's gonna come to pass you
know i'm very spiritual because you know
that god promised us these things you
know we written on the pain we okay this
this
the goal is really i feel like you know
it's just she forgot but we still got to
do our part as well
you know we just can't rely on god to do
everything you know people
pray to these things and they say all
right god we went on you doing you just
sit back and just wait on god
no you gotta put in your work you gotta
you gotta you know once god see you
doing that that's when he gonna elevate
you he gonna give you the strength to
like keep going
do you put timelines on your goals like
i want to achieve this by this
time i um like how i write in my goals i
do them yearly
so i i want to accomplish these things
this year
so i don't i don't know when it's going
to happen i just know in between this
year
these goals gonna happen so what's
what's on
the goal list for 2018 uh one of my
biggest goals is to be on tv
yeah and how specifically though like
you want to be a tv show you want to be
on a talk show like
how do you do how clear is this goal
yeah family
is it yeah either a tv show or a movie
okay that's acting though yeah yeah
acting yeah
yeah is this your tv show or
um just tv however however
yeah i want to i want to be on tv 2018.
that's a big goal that's my biggest goal
right now okay that yeah
why i have i have zero doubt my man is
gonna happen
you've you've been such a thrill to have
on this show
it's really been an honor to be able to
capture this moment in your appreciation
man
i appreciate it i know you're very busy
and the fact you're willing to sit down
with the hot breath of earth oh yeah man
i enjoyed it man appreciate you
man yeah thanks for having me before we
get out of here man
is there anything else you want the
world to know um i would just say man
hey
find your purpose in life man find out
what it is that you really want to do
and
stay consistent with it and make sure it
brings a positive light
to the world yeah let them use you
let them use you desi banks thanks for
being on hot breath my man thanks bro
all right oh yeah
all right great job
it was awesome